dann schauen wir uns doch mal die
letzten Jahre an und warum irgendwie
junge Leute vielleicht auch das Gefühl
haben dass die Politik keine ernsthaften
Antworten findet gucken wir nur zurück
bis zur coronapandemie wo wir erlebt
haben so Schülerinnen Studierende
Auszubildende waren das wo Leute am
wenigsten interessiert hat wo es immer
hieß wir machen jetzt was und dann gab
es dre Jahre lang online Uni dann gab's
jahrelang online Schule was wirklich ein
Konzept ist was vorne und hinten nicht
aufgeht
das weiß jeder der irgendwie mit Kindern
arbeitet das funktioniert nicht jetzt in
der Energiekrise waren die Studierenden
die als allerletztes irgendwie in der
energiepreishilfen bekommen
habenes das stimmt alles aber es gibt
junge Menschen die in Diktaturen leben
die die die unseren Wohlstand nicht
haben die nicht diesen Pessimismus
Teilen deswegen ich sag
ursachenforschung ist eine Sache aber es
gibt auch ein kulturelles
[Musik]
Phänomen